[Music]
oh man did you see that awesomeness the
ancient power that Zelda just unleashed
upon those monstrosities I mean aside
from awakening it at just the right time
cut it conveniently I am glad her
ceiling power does a lot more than just
you know seal evil away I mean she
basically just set off a bomb of light
that destroyed all her enemies right in
front of her hi such a pity link was
already unconscious before getting to
see Zelda do her awesome stuff actually
wait a second he wasn't down just yet
was he nope there he is right there
alive and well enjoying the view of the
deaf machines I mean yeah his stamina
will had probably run out a while ago
and he may have only had one or two
hearts left but he was alive right
I know sometimes in-game cinematics work
differently from in-game logic but if
the three decades of Zelda games are any
indication of what link can do that
means that if he was not on fire and
alive even on 1/4 heart with no stamina
at all all my boy link needs is a
breather and some hearty simmered fruit
and he's back in the actual but right
after Zelda's blast goes off and I mean
right after it goes off he falls to the
ground only to be immediately considered
dead by the princess if you don't know
where I'm going with this just yet I'll
just hurry up and tell you
Zelda's powers have taken on many
different forms and abilities over the
years what if her quote-unquote ceiling
powers actually ended up sealing the
deal on link here who was otherwise
going to survive you know given that he
wasn't shot in the face hold up don't
head down to the comments just yet let's
get through the video first roll the
title
you
hey guys just real quick before I get to
the nitty-gritty if you enjoy my content
make sure you're subscribed to the
channel with that bell icon so you don't
miss out on all my Nintendo stuff to
come YouTube has a tendency to
repeatedly recommend videos to people
without them actually being subscribed
to that channel so sometimes you'll be
watching a channels videos and you won't
even know you're not subscribed but
channels can't grow without subscribers
so remember hit that sub button and
enable those notifications so that you
always know what's going on at Maspeth
Hema bandit and that's enough of that on
to the aforementioned nitty gritty so as
I mentioned briefly at the start of the
video
Lincoln Zelda's final scene together 100
years ago ends with link being defeated
maybe even killed and his limp body
didn't hit the ground until after
Zelda's blast of light goes off which
admittedly looks and acts a whole lot
different than anything else we've ever
seen Zelda do in the games even at the
end of breath the wild this made me
start thinking real hard about
everything involved in this situation
from the battle to Zelda's powers to
link falling to the shrine of
Resurrection itself but here's a spoiler
alert for you there is so much to talk
about here that I'm actually going to do
my first two-part theory on this subject
with the first video um that's this one
you're watching right now covering
Zelda's real powers and what happened in
this cutscene and the second one being
about Link's possible death and the
shrine of resurrections real purpose but
for this video let's talk about Zelda in
order to get a grasp on what actually
happened in the scene let's piece
together two things one what it looks
like happened and to what we've seen
Zelda's sacred powers do in other parts
of the Zelda franchise in the first
place Zelda's power seemed to be
directly tied to her will this may seem
obvious but it's important to note in
order to understand the true nature of
her powers we see this across the entire
franchise but in this scene specifically
she's able to straight-up kill the
Guardians when both Link's life and her
own are threatened let's take a look at
what happens when the blast goes off it
spreads out in a giant sphere as is
typical of you know a bomb or detonation
going off followed by the Guardians
falling down and glitching out as what
looks like Ganon's malice leaves its
host
then link also falls down let me ask you
what exactly is Zelda supposed to be
sealing away here one could say that
she's sealing Ganon's power you know
kind of sucking it out of the Guardians
and that's why they become cleansed of
his power but that's not what's
happening here
at the end of the game we see what
sealing away Ganon's malice looks like
and while it may look similar at first
glance what would the similar orb of
light expanding outward from Zelda's
position it's different because it
literally sucks calamity Ganon into a
black hole sort of prison a seal if you
would that's not what happens in the
previous cutscene at all those guardians
are quite honestly losing their lives
because if she was really just cleansing
them of Ganon's influence wouldn't they
simply revert back to their normal
programming that we know they were
already in from prior cutscenes I mean
that's what happened to each divine
beast when link cleansed them of Ganon's
influence you literally see the malleus
exiting their divine bods and their
little red lights turning blue meaning
pay no more kill the princess it's time
to kill Ganon beep-boop but again this
is clearly not what happens to these
Guardians who were threatening the lives
of Zelda in link they're down and out of
commission permanently as we see from
the present-day ruins of the death
robots not sealed away not cleansed but
how is this possible Ken Zelda really
just killed things like that let's take
a look at her powers over the entire
franchise and try to find an answer
chronologically speaking in the first
zelda game called Skyward Sword
spoiler alert by the way she's revealed
to literally be the reincarnation of the
goddess hylia herself that's some pretty
big deal type stuff meaning that the
royal bloodline is literally the
bloodline of the gods huh neat
but since zelda harbors the goddess
within her bloodline one would assume
that would come with the goddess's
powers right otherwise I mean really
what's the point those powers the plural
would include the ability to
telepathically communicate with others
namely link as shown in several games
like a Link to the Past and of course
this one you may have heard of called
breath wild fellow youtuber Nintendo
black Crysis did a theory a couple years
ago about the true nature of her powers
in breath of the wild concluding that
she can also even turn into a spirit of
light her
self which makes sense to me in Twilight
Princess she can seemingly alter time
when she slows it down to make a plea to
the light spirits at the last moment and
even ends up warping Lincoln herself to
their realm a trait that she also
appears to perform once again when
warping linked to the battlefield in
breadth of the wild in ocarina of time
she's able to create a magically
enhanced disguise that enables her to
convincingly take on the physical
appearance of the opposite sex but this
particular ability could also be the
sheikah training she received from Impa
which of course the Yaga having the same
technology as the sheikah are also
capable of performing in breath of the
wild but at the end of ocarina of time
she has another power where she holds
Ganon down to enable link to deliver the
final blow an ability I can only assume
she's performing again in breath of the
wild for 100 years while she shares his
cocoon and prevents him from unleashing
the dark beast Ganon's rage upon Hyrule
holding him down in a similar fashion so
that Lincoln you know hurry up and quit
looking for Couric's and come over there
and beat Ganon like he's supposed to do
so so far we have telepathy spirit
transformation and travel warping light
blasts sealing disguise and just
preventative force or whatever that's
called and if I'm missing any of her
powers let me know when I comment below
but she's kind of all over the place
isn't she I mean it seems like she just
kind of gets to do whatever she puts her
mind to I mean what's the secret behind
her powers which seems to be just
whatever force she wills into existence
well I'm glad I scripted you to ask me
that question just now it's actually
revealed to us in the game diminished
cap which unfortunately not too many
have played myself included I'm ashamed
to admit but it's revealed to us in that
game that officially there is a force in
the realm of Hyrule that quite frankly
functions a lot like the force from the
Star Wars franchise this force of power
that governs all things is called the
light force and it's kind of a big deal
in the game what with the body of the
game named Vaati trying to capture it at
all hey those of you watching who have
played the game back me up on this and
wouldn't you know it the elusive light
force that governs all things exists
within the bloodline of your favorite
Princess Zelda the Hyrule historia
describes this mysterious power
as quote a source of infinite power from
the heavens that holds the enormous
power of the force which originally
dwelled in all things it's later proven
within the elemental sanctuary that
Zelda is the bearer of this force now
let's sum up some things here Zelda the
incarnation of goddess hylia
is in possession of the light force
which is a source of infinite power from
the heavens
I believe those two factors go hand in
hand to put it simply our princess Zelda
has the infinite power of the Gods at
her disposal ok ok ok so bringing this
back from the heavens down to earth with
Zelda's infinite light force being
explained why was it so difficult for
her to unlock the power in breadth of
the wild well to be honest with you it's
probably from all the intense pressure
placed upon her by her father
hashtag parenting hashtag bad dad she
just didn't realize that the secret to
her powers was simply her own will it's
not in what clothes she's wearing or
what shrine she's praying to it's her
own force of will that's why she can
accomplish so many things over all the
games and they're all embedded within
the light so back to the original scene
were discussing the baddies come up link
is pretty low on HP so Zelda steps in
and wills every moving thing around her
to die including link but that's where
next week's video comes in in the part 2
to this theory we're going to cover
whether or not link actually died there
in this field and what exactly the
shrine of resurrection took a hundred
long years to accomplish and furthermore
why the shrine was built in the first
place 10,000 years ago for a hero that
seemingly didn't need to use it you'll
want to be here for it so once again be
sure you hit that subscribe button with
the Bell icon to experience the second
part of this theory next weekend and on
that note thank you guys so much for
watching I was really excited to get all
this out to you so please let me know
what you think in the comments below
also please be sure to LIKE this video
if you enjoyed the content to get it
spread around more on YouTube trust me
every like counts also also as always
huge thanks to my fantastic patrons of
which I have a
arrival the amazing geeky girl
experience is now an official supporter
and I'm excited to have her aboard if
you're interested in getting your name
up here at the end of each of my videos
please feel free to check out the
patreon link in the description below
also down there are links to my social
media pages so come on over and say hey
that's all I've got in this video so in
the meantime be sure to check out my
other theories on the amazing Legend of
Zelda this is masking tuna bandits
signing out wash those hands people and
stay safe
[Music]